genau 200 jahre nach der
veröffentlichung des bekannten
frankenstein romans haben
forschungsteams weltweit nicht nur
mischwesen wie menschen schimären im
labor geschaffen es gibt auch konkrete
pläne das erste mal gezielt in die
evolution einzugreifen weitere beispiele
für solche projekte aller frankenstein
und wo demnächst eine genetische
atombombe gezündet wird jetzt in klicks
um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
wir haben hier ja schon öfter darüber
berichtet schon länger machen gentechnik
teams auch nicht mehr vor experimenten
mit menschen halt und es ist zum einen
wirklich sensationell was heute
biomedizinische möglich ist auf der
anderen seite ist die forschung auf
diesem gebiet auch wirklich
furchteinflößend und macht mir öfter mal
gänsehaut aber nicht so im positiven wie
bei diesem beispiel in china haben
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
genmanipulierte embryonen geschaffen und
die hätten sie tatsächlich zu menschen
heranwachsen lassen können noch ist das
nicht passiert die embryonen wurden
nicht ausgetragen aber das ist
wahrscheinlich nur noch eine frage der
zeit
konkret haben sie intakte gen abschnitte
in die erbkranken menschlichen embryonen
eingesetzt
in drei von sechs fällen verlief die
korrektur der gene tatsächlich
erfolgreich das alles führt uns in eine
zeit in der es im bereich der
reproduktionsmedizin das normal sein
wird menschen zu designen in eine etwas
andere richtung geht die forschung im
bereich neurobiologie
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
erschaffen so genannte gehirn organo ide
menschliche stammzellen werden zu
hirnzellen ausdifferenziert diese
wachsen dann tatsächlich zu einem mini
gehirn heran man kann es kaum glauben
aber die zellen knüpfen verbindung und
bilden sechs zellschichten auf typisch
für die großhirnrinde könnten solche
fast gehirne da nicht auch anfangen zu
fühlen oder zu denken
die beteiligten forschungsteams tun
diese zweifel ab schließlich bekämen die
minne gehirne jack einen sinnes input
und zudem sei ihre größe viel zu gering
bislang sind die mini gehirne nicht
durchblutet sobald sie so groß sind wie
eine linse reicht die versorgung mit
sauerstoff und nährstoffen nicht mehr
aus doch genau das will jetzt ein
neurochirurg von der universität von
pennsylvania ändern und man seine
experimente sind wirklich unfassbar cars
sein forschungsteam baut solche
menschlichen fast mini gehirne in die
sehrinde von ratten ein und das mit
erfolg die kleinen kunst gehirne sind so
also mit blut und sinneseindrücken
versorgt und ja man kann es wirklich so
formulieren diese menschen
eine schimäre machen es möglich dass
menschliches gewebe durch ratten augen
schaut und so die welt wahrnimmt
ich habe echt ein ungutes gefühl dabei
wie groß ist hier die gefahr dass sich
diese im labor erschaffenen kreaturen
anna gegen uns wenden
frankenstein des größten derzeit
überschlagen sich tatsächlich die
nachrichten aus diesem bereich die
biomedizin und die genetik übernehmen
quasi ingenieurs aufgaben und
manipulieren das leben so wie es gefällt
der schlüssel dazu ist sie so genannte
chris pratt technik über die wir hier
schon öfter berichtet haben diese gegen
schere macht die manipulation von erbgut
sehr präzise und ist zudem noch sehr
preiswert außerdem ist die methode
selbst für anfänger sehr einfach
anzuwenden demnächst werden vielleicht
auch organspender überflüssig denn der
plan ist es menschliche organe wie
nieren beispielsweise im schweinen
heranzuzüchten andere forschungsteams
haben das ziel ausgestorbene tierarten
wie beispielsweise das mammut wieder
auferstehen zu lassen
das hat man ja schon hier bei kik sowie
anderes sehr erfolgreiches
forschungsgebiet ist die synthetische
biologie mit deren hilfe bakterien
design werden ein paar projekte die sich
bereits in der umsetzung befinden
bakterien die protokollieren wie die
krankheit ihrer wirte verläuft oder aber
bakterien die dreifarbig sehen können
zum schluss komme ich jetzt noch zu
einem projekt das so wirklich einmalig
auf der erde wäre in burkina faso wird
ein forschungsteam demnächst wohl das
erste mal gezielt in die evolution
eingreifen der konkrete plan sieht so
aus dass im bauerndorf bana mücken
ausgesetzt werden die in ihrem erbgut
ein unfruchtbarkeit gehen haben laut den
bisher durchgeführten
computersimulationen wird sich dieses
gehen dann in der gesamten mücken
population ausbreiten
die idee des forschungsteams das
übrigens im auftrag der bill & melinda
gates stiftung arbeitet malaria
einzudämmen denn der malaria-erreger
nutzt diese mücken als wird und diese
wird es dann wohl nur noch in
verminderter anzahl geben wenn der plan
aufgeht und der mensch die natur
tatsächlich austricksen kann dieses
verfahren wird in der
wissenschaftssprache übrigens als jean
drive bezeichnet
kritiker nennen es genetische atombombe
denn die gene werden sich wohl so rasch
verbreiten wie es auch bei einer nur
klären kettenreaktionen der fall ist
natürlich biologisch also ganz schnell
plötzlich sei nicht in
sekundenbruchteilen all diese projekte
lassen sich doch irgendwie mit dem
frankenstein roman in verbindung bringen
bringen doch inwieweit haben wir daraus
gelernt werden die heutigen experimente
in den genen laboren dieser welt in
einer katastrophe wird die menschheit
enden feststehen falls man wird diese
experimente nicht stoppen können doch es
braucht instanzen die solche projekte um
gentech geschöpfe kontrollieren und
daraufhin prüfen ob sie zum wohl der
menschen sind wenn ihr zuallererst neues
zum thema und zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei
whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video garantiert
ihr könnt direkt eben vorschläge machen
oder andere ideen vorschlagen der
direkte draht zu mir einfach
draufklicken gestern abend haben es
schon wahnsinn 2000 gemacht und ich habe
wirklich jede nachricht beantwortet nein
wie ein fass ziele
hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf
klicken das mammut wiederbeleben doktor
frankenstein wird realität und natürlich
abonnieren nicht vergessen ansonsten bis
dann gleich krank